france pour france 24 2 nathalie à
mendoza
dans le centre-ville de tarente dans le
sud de l'italie un événement
exceptionnel se préparent les membres de
l' orchestre de chambre de kiev resté
bloqué en italie à cause du début de la
guerre vont donner un concert à
l'intérieur de la salle ils préparent
leur instrument
tous essaient partage d'un sentiment
l'angoissent pour leur famille restée en
ukraine est plus qu un set et pour
chaque concert je le joue avec de la
douleur donateurs et avec de la peur
pour ma famille je sais qu'à chaque fois
que les sirènes sonne ils doivent courir
au refuge antibombe c'est terrible je me
demande en permanence comment ils vont
s'ils sont encore vives et
le concert commence le public accueille
les musiciens avec enthousiasme
premier morceau
l'hymne ukrainien
une mélodie transformé ici en un message
de paix et de résistance
c'est difficile pour nous de jouer de la
musique encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais on est conscient que c'est notre
meilleure façon de parler au monde
nous voulons dire au monde que l'ukraine
est une nation de paix
mais nous sommes aussi un peuple fort et
nous soutenons notre armée
ce concert est aussi l'occasion de
lancer une collecte de dons pour aider
les 14 membres de cet orchestre
on a déjà recueilli
2575 euros cela servira surtout pour
qu'ils puissent rejoindre leur famille
[Musique]
c'était très émouvant et ils ont joué
tellement bien je suis contente d'avoir
contribué
on veut démontrer notre solidarité avec
le peuple ukrainien qui vit un moment si
difficile
[Musique]
une solidarité bienvenue pour ces
musiciens qui n'ont qu'un espoir pouvoir
un jour retourner en ukraine et
retrouver leur ancienne vie